the jurgen experience have you guys seen
jamie foxx as trump
it's incredible i got tagged in that 9
000 times it's the only trump i've ever
heard that's better than yours oh it's
better uh well black people are better
at things this is a challenge
it's real is it better
he's a black guy black guys
they're okay pretty good
dude some people are way better at the
conversational trump i can't do that
like the
what are you gonna do in 2024 mr trump
is it you haven't announced you're
running i haven't announced it the
crooked fbi they went into my house not
good they didn't find anything
i don't have anything boy people are on
the fence now there's like pro and con
anti-fbi people with no information
is the same people so now the left keeps
tweeting oh now all the all of a sudden
the right's anti-police
but then it's like the people on the
right are all they get to tweet oh all
of a sudden the left's pro police they
do this every single [ __ ] thing the
same people they do it everywhere just
use whatever they want to get ahead they
have no real beliefs
trump won they all said the election's
rigged it's a rigged election and then
when trump won oh the election is great
i mean
it's crazy so yeah when trump won the
left was like he was a russian spy right
this is [ __ ] he shouldn't have won
that was russian when biden wanted biden
wins they're like shut up the results
are in exactly yeah and then the rights
like this they this was [ __ ] they're
the same and the exact same guys just
looking at all of them going like oh i
want to make fun of all of you i do make
fun of all of them you got to stay in
the middle and observe yeah
you guys are all hypocrites
i agree with more people in the left
than i do on the right on most things
but i still think they're the most
ridiculous i like them left accept gay
rights
[Laughter]
mr trump how do you feel about gay
rights
i like it but they're going a little
overboard with the dancing
a lot of dancing i don't know about that
no trump go on matt and shane's
please
would that be amazing what would you get
trump on your show trump doesn't drink
dude at all you'd have chicken for him
we get some mcdonald's and amphetamines
for the boy imagine if that's the first
time he drinks is on your show oh
heard about it i'll try it imagine his
twitter
his drunk twitter yeah his twitter
before was insane but his
drunk twitter would be bananas
like check out this sunset oh my god
tones down a little bit like
oh man that's a character yeah
gillian keys write it we [ __ ] that up
that was a layup we didn't even think of
that
yeah just do it now just do it now yeah
still doing it do it now she's doing
great
trump would be [ __ ] amazing sure yeah
his wife died he has a drink to get over
it did i talk about this last time when
i went to mar-a-lago and you saw him i
saw them wait i saw the king dude i went
to mar-a-lago wait
i was in mar-a-lago what it was me and
like 10 people it was just a regular day
of monologue like a field trip no i got
in there
i'm not gonna name names you went to
mar-a-lago to meet trump specifically i
went to mar-a-lago because i was doing
palm beach improv yep and some people
that are that work there or work
you know
on the staff or whatever their fans they
showed up came the show they were like
do you want to go to mar-a-lago tomorrow
and i was like talking to the right guy
i was like
yeah
that [ __ ] was so nice
was it pretty yeah look at it it's
beautiful i mean fantastic no one's dude
the only people there are 70 year old
billionaires it's not margarita and
they're all wearing maga hats dude sure
but not just regular red magnets like
flat friendship can we get yeah it's 200
000 a year listen to this yes listen to
this
what
please what if we have a conversation
with donald we go we don't want to be
affiliated with you in any way anyway we
would just like to rent something down
on your property
yeah imagine if we never even addressed
it never everybody knows that we we
moved our studio
to mar-a-lago before only protect our
people looks like a park and behind us
he'd be like [ __ ] park ranger hats
and [ __ ] and pine trees that's the set
can we eat
our logo you have no idea how much i
would
i would donate
whatever money for the membership we
never talk about it and then if it gets
brought up in interviews like we can't
yeah oh you can't disclose
dude there's a gold plated
i think it was the constitution
dude that's the main room jesus christ
jesus it's small though it's small it's
smaller than you'd say shut up no i mean
there you have it this is like the main
rooms wow you know who's doing stand-up
now is don junior really uh he's doing
stand up
he was just at palm beach here's my
thought on that building like look at
that can i see that image again oh
now if this was in the home of a
professor yeah people would think this
is magnificent if this is a guy who's
this genius man who wrote books on
gene therapy and whatever and just
[ __ ] published works and made
millions of dollars somehow and this was
his home he'd be like what an opulent
home
but you look at it and you know it's
trump's you're like this crazy is it
it's a it's a resort but he lives on a
wing okay
it's his fault but it's his house it's
his house he has i thought it was his
camp live in his house dude it's a
resort his house is a [ __ ] resort
jamie it's the manchester look at that
kodak black at mar-a-lago look at this
place shout out kodak black dude bro
he's ballin out of control this is what
you're supposed to do when you're a 78
year old billionaire you're supposed to
be balling out of control
live on a resort where everybody knows
it's yours so the only people that come
are people who love you yeah so there's
all these but thank you for the tax cut
he controls the music we're doing the
right thing with china you were doing
the right thing was he
i don't know they all feel maybe
how about
he controls the music of course he does
he literally thinks it's it's well i
mean number one is uh ymca that's his
number one choice he loves that song
does
yeah it gets the people going dude he
knows
he knows it is catchy uh didn't he like
go out dancing to it once
yeah i think so like if there was
something
dance
but wasn't there like a video of him
dancing to a song and the the people who
made the song objected to it
oh yeah
wasn't there something i know there was
no
we're not gonna take it and then dee
snyder
kodak black chills dude who's kodak
black he's the man he's a rapper he's
there he is with rudy giuliani
oh wow i think
trump pardoned
trump pardon kodak wow really and asap
rocky
that's a good move trump said if i was
trump that's uh i would go
yeah that's a good move rappers love
trump yeah yeah that's a good move if
you can park yeah they're millionaires
yeah he lives like he lives like they
rap about just say boys just settle down
did you know you're young and you're
making billions yeah i've done this
before i've been in this business guys
you're black
[Laughter]
you see the kanye dog
oh [ __ ] kodak black what a great guy and
the kanye dock when he's watching carl
dapping them up
they're dapping
he dabs people oh he's gonna fix it
what's his limp for
probably uh hurt himself do you get a
fat lady light lady's a cane
[Laughter]
that's baller ball or [ __ ] oh my god
hey
help me walk
yeah
[ __ ] a cane
get me a sturdy gal
oh my god that's so ridiculous that was
that was wild i was like that was the
first time i've been like for real like
oh [ __ ] there he is wow yeah like he was
just
he was so cl he was from us to jamie
just stand there and i was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]